the gyro can experience a lot of very
weird people out there there's a lot of
very weird people here in LA all the
weirdest this is the weirdest spot
because this is a spot where they think
they're going to finally get that
attention that they deserve and sexually
weird there's a lot of weird sex in it
and in LA come on me talking about what
you're doing
well I'm in a relationship now but I was
a very much I'll tell you so I got some
good stories okay
please this is this is a pretty good one
oh well I want to tell you the one when
I was started hit bottom I've gone I've
had some issues with sex but one real
bad story was I there was a girl I was I
went to this clothing store and I used
to be really in a big girls like very
big girls how big I mean as big as you
could muster nerd plus I mean I'm I was
into it all Yeah right I like a thick
girl anyway my girl now is not she's
very small right but deal with it
no I love her and she's great she's hot
it's weird in ski clothes hahaha
so it doesn't feed her a lot you know
those relationships where there's a
feeder you know about that know guys
that are real this is like where the fad
thing that goes beyond just like a like
I think it's hot need to like up like a
fetish so there'll be a guy like me like
a skinny kind of weakling guy that's
like bringing his fat girlfriend like
Twinkies and Ho Hos and roast beef and
stuffing and just be like here honey
keep eating and she gets bigger and
bigger so there's like a feeder and then
there's like a big woman that just
eventually I guess grows and grows and
grows and Wow his erection grows with or
something like that
whoa what now this relationship is
defined like when you say there's a type
yeah this is defined like and websites
where they talk about this yeah I mean
you could look that up I mean that's
that I'm not but is it like a community
but well yet I don't know if there's a
community because they have to bring
they have to get it's hard to get that
many cranes to bring people to the
meeting so what I mean like an online
community where this is all discussed
I'm sure yours yeah no this is a real
thing have you heard of it I've never
heard of that have you been trying this
with your new girl no no no no I'm not I
was never like that for me I mean this
is like a weird psychological like I'm
gonna bring you food it's being
dominated by a person that's passive I
think
you know the dominatrix in this case
doesn't even have to do anything but sit
around and eat you know that's
interesting
that's interesting but anyway I don't
know why I even brought that up that's
weird sex stuff so this person was a was
big and I went to the store she was the
she was the parking attendant at the
store and this is like well into comedy
so I'm like on some level of public
figure I mean not like a huge public
figure but enough that it's like I
shouldn't be like at random approaching
maybe I should who knows anyway this
girl she was bigger and she was the
parking lot attendant at this store and
I somehow started talking to her and got
her phone number and then sort of
texting with her and I this is so I
remember I had a show that night in
Orange County I was at a I was at a
comedy show at UC Irvine and I brought
my friend Jacob Jacob sear off down to
the down to the show and and she was
texting with me while I was at the show
in Orange County and was like oh you
should have said something you know I
would have sucked your dick in the
parking lot and I was like oh really
well activated like yeah it's a little
dick getting hard like that Rob Ford guy
you know and and she's like yeah I mean
you know what you come by my house
tonight I'll suck your dick tonight and
I was like yeah that's a great you live
and she's like Compton and I and I start
doing the math and I'm like okay Orange
County if I'm driving back to my home
and Silver Lake Compton is sort of in a
weird way on the way so I [ __ ] get
rid of Jacob you know I go I say to some
other comic like can you please give
Jacob ride home I've got a direction
right now and like okay like I don't
tell anybody what's going on my friend
my good friend Jacob was like why are
you slumming me off on this stranger
who's gonna game right on my leg and
he's got some business to take care of
it's like it's 11:30 at night what but
he's a pervert too so I'm driving I pull
off the exit in Compton where this girl
says she's gonna suck my dick and and I
start driving through Compton and it's
getting like stuck weirder and weirder
and worse and worse the further I go and
I keep texting her and she's I keep
going keep going and I pull down this
alley and and it's like an abandoned
alley and it's like it's like you want
to talk about having two different
brains you know what I mean like I knew
my brain my good brain my big brain was
telling me like you're going to be
murdered this is a situation
where your I'm driving down an alley
there's an empty field on one side
there's like tract housing on the other
side like it's there's no streetlights
she's and she keeps going keep going
keep going I'm at the end of the at the
end of this alley I'm waiting for you
keep going I just know I'm gonna get
there her brothers are gonna come out
surround the car - I'm dead
my cars dead and I keep driving forward
because I have this other brain that's
like this little eighth bonobo brain
that's going like at the end of this
road there's a [ __ ] keep driving
blood of awaits I swear you couldn't
there is no place in LA that's more
well-suited to murder a white person
than this alley Wow
so how's it go down she comes outside
take a deep breath she gets in the car
she gives me a [ __ ] and I Drive when
you came was it like the most like
sneaky coming ever like I got here the
ignition was already on oh the other
crazy thing is she lives in she lives in
Compton one of the first thing she says
before she starts giving me head is uh
oh yeah I love suckin dick I'll suck
anybody's dick except for and then she
just drops an N bomb like a heart is and
i'm like 'i live in Compton and my other
again two brains my brain is like don't
comment on the racism don't comment on
the racism she come on she's about to
give you a [ __ ] don't even and I
didn't I focused
I focused up why I got through it Wow
she was that the last time you saw her
yeah it's the last time I saw did you
change your phone number I I wait I'm
lying to you no I changed my fight I
erased the phone number uh and told her
I have a girlfriend now I didn't have a
girlfriend I have a girlfriend now
erased her phone number then I like
maybe six months later I drove by that
place again got her phone number again
started texting there and then erased
her phone number and never I never went
back ah how big was she she was too big
Wow she was like to 250 probably have
you been with a lot of big girls
uh yeah have you ever had any kind of
cleaning problems where they smell more
like poop or does that get you like a
bigger boner when you
because I mean they don't smell the best
it's a serious question mother it seems
like a serious question
he's throwing ibogaine at me as he asked
them um no I mean you know that people
shower okay but I hear what you're
saying they can't get all those nooks
and crannies if you're talking about
that big fifties not that big bro yeah I
mean I'm talking about like five
hundreds Ralphie may sighs oh I know I
have [ __ ] Rafi may Rafi music you
gotta [ __ ] yeah I bet he is guys there
was another girl when I first moved to
town that she was like a she was like a
kind of she was real intense speaking of
power dynamics she was she's the kind of
girl she kept going like put your
cigarette out on me put your cigarette
out Christ and I was like III can't I
don't I don't think I can do that and
she would be like she was very
aggressive and pain oriented and she was
biting me and like biting my dick and
biting my balls Oh God and yeah but it
was also hot but also I didn't like the
biting part like I'll stop ow and at one
point she an old Jewish like that now
stop Wow and at one point she looks down
she's like going down I mean she stops
and she goes what is that and you know
that kind of what is that the way you
would say like if you were going down on
a girl and you saw like some sort of
sore or something and I'm like what and
I look and there is a contusion like a
straight up like bubble blood blister on
my scrotum from her writing from her
bite I say you [ __ ] did that and
she's and then afterwards she was like
that was great we should do it again and
I texted her I was like I don't know I
think you maybe play a little too rough
for me and she goes uh okay
she's like no like I'll dial it back no
like it's okay let's try it was just
like if you can't [ __ ] ride the
dragon with with the scales that I have
then get off god damn man Jesus Christ I
got more have you ever had the cloer
like the next day where you're like why
is my bow and you just look on your back
and it's just like oh yeah yeah I've had
that but that's not that's sorted normal
that's girls just getting caught up in
the throes of passion that's not
fighting you're correct oh yeah
that's why I lamping down your scrotum I
had other I had I've had sexual I don't
know if you've you don't seem like
you've had because you seem like you've
been having like fun sex experiences
your whole life what makes you say that
is it just like you know you're like
good-looking and you've been you've been
famous for a long time and if you feel
like you think I feel done sex that well
know what I feel like I feel like you're
the type of dude that likes to have sex
only with good-looking women yeah I'm
crazy like that yeah you're like an
aberrant a sexual deviant in that way no
but there's like for me I used to get
off on like hooking up with people that
were not as a track I it was hot purpose
it was hot right right you know I was
lying hot to them yeah and I would find
a attractiveness in people that weren't
objectively attractive hmm that makes
sense yeah so okay so what we were
talking about earlier like that's your
king so like the drug thing whatever led
you to be an impulsive drug person led
you for a while to be an impulsive sex
person so wasn't even almost a natural
sort of attracts like wow that's a
pretty girl she likes me I like her I
love her personality you didn't like her
personality she's talking about dropping
embalm she won't suck [ __ ] dicks it
would be well she's she's you like still
enough about you that's hot not
interesting enough though I actually
have one oh yeah it's real big and black
there was a shocker to her yeah she was
really fun what but nothing there was a
girl I thought about that we're in a
minute man I was lying I snuck him every
day look where I lived wha
uh ya know for sure that became the
thing and it also is very
compartmentalized I would be like in a
store I remember one instance in
particular I was at the store at like 2
o'clock in the morning shopping for I
was a Safeway getting some groceries and
this woman walked around the corner and
she was big and in the way that I liked
and I started I did you ever get like
have you ever gotten so horny you start
getting cold yeah you know I mean you
look a little shiver ease I'm not even
flirting with this woman she's just a
woman shopping at 2:00 in the morning
for [ __ ] Cheez Whiz or whatever and
I'm like I gotta figure out a way and
can you imagine if I walked up to her
with a shivering like a 2:00 in the
morning like hey how are you
there's no way he's [ __ ] me that's go
so crazy cuz it's just cuz she's big or
something
yeah something what else could it be if
it wasn't the big thing no I guess
you're right it's the big I must be
right that's when it would get the most
pronounced it was pretty intense wow
that's amazing I've had sex while I sold
after the woman left cuz thought I was
rational
he thought I was rational no cuz I'm oh
she was like scratching this area of her
body when she left I was like freaked
out so hard but I went into my bathroom
I started Lysol in my legs like shape
and then dish soap and then Lysol and
the next day I speaking of 12-step
meetings I went to my first and only sex
addicts Anonymous meeting I was just
like something's got to change - look at
your face was awesome you know there's
no there's very little way for you to
convince yourself that you're just like
a young man swinging around having a
good time engaging in the regular
sexuality of all human beings when
you're spraying Lysol I'm sure I got you
uh oh that's awesome
so I went and one of the things about s
sex well the first thing I realized when
I got to a sex addicts Anonymous meeting
is I may have a problem or something I
may have a compulsive sexuality but I
don't have what these people have I mean
there's something else that they're
talking about what were they talking
about they were talking about I'll look
I'll start looking at pornography at
4:00 p.m. and then all of a sudden the
Sun will be coming up whoa and I was
like oh or like I I had a home but I
took all of my money and spent it on
prostitutes you know that kind of thing
Wow it was very intense it was stuff
that I did not really fully relate to
you